It was time for George Melies!
-Boom!
-(crew) Introoo
(crew) Bo doo doo do do do
Boo doo doo do do do do!
No?
(intro)
This powerful medium sits in a sweet pot --
Sp-sp (crew laugh)
-Sweet pot.
As filmmakers started to experiment with narrative film they began to establish a language through different editing techniques and
camera movements, I'm gonna do that again.
The Lumiere brothers had lots of experience in business, engineering, manufacturing, and
Photography. Okay.
He thought of mo--he thought of motion pictures as--as an add-on to phonograph. Which is -- (clicks tongue) he thought of mo--
We're gonna get this guys so everybody settle down, everybody just calm down. We're going to get this.
It's inescapable like FBI--
It's inescapable like bluhlbluh
Not many films are shot
Bluhbluhbluh woo mi mi mi.
In 1894 a Canadian entrepreneur named Andrew Hollen opened the first
kinetoscope parlor in New York City, charging 25 cents, ha!
(crew laughs) Ha! Yeah.
-Then, holy (beep) he reverse engineered the anomanograph
-(crew laughs)
So it worked as its own camera too- not many films are actually filmed on film these days, anymore.
Even though Edison and Dixon originally
hoped to synchronize the sound from a phonograph to the images in the kinetoscope (breath in)
They never quite figured out how to do it. Now at the very beginning of history before all these
Innovations existed film started--hubluhbluh--started out of the collective still images viewed one after another in rapid succession
Which creates the illusion of motion.
One take wonder.
The camera was hard to move and they--and only one wadawah
A single viewer exhibition device that you would
use to watch the kineto--kine oo nam oo--kinetograph films.
The idea was to create a coin-operated
entertainment machine that produced images to go along with music or speech that played from a
I want to do it again.
...and from that trick came an art form that the blend of literature drama--fah fah fe fu!
and music
-(crew) Fah fah fruit?
That's french.
If another frame appears within that fifth of a second your brain won't register the black space between them
You'll just perceive that im--blah hoo-hah. Hey!
Before Edison and his lab had even built their viewing machine he applied for two preliminary
claims with the U.S. patent office. One for the plans for the device. One for his plans for his device--for the device and one
For his na--for its name
You've probably experienced this concept at some point. A new technology comes out and at first
we're all marveling at what it can do ooh, I can--I got camera in my pocket
It's a phone and a camera at the same time, wow!
Bah ben ta be hmm.
Edison ever the money
hog (chuckles)
The guy that invented--the guy with the chronophotographic gun.
Which gives you some idea of how they felt about working for a guy like (mutters)
Defined in 1912 by the Czech born flahah psychologist Max Wertheimer.
-I nailed it, right?
(crew)Yes
The five phenomenon is an optical illusion that lets you see the--leheh
Series of images in rapid (quick mutter) succession as in any one moment.
Moving on. (clears throat)
The idea was to create a coin-operated entertainment machine that produced images to go along with music or speech that played from a ph--phono--
Phonograph, huh! Inventors were working independently all over Europe and the United bleh
But that's not all once the film has been developed the Lumiere device could reconfigure into a projection ma--machine as well
It does so many things. It's great.
Love it. Perfect.
Let's move on.
(sing-song) When is the last time you heard a really good story?
Now people have been telling stories since we've had language and they've been using
pictures even animunimum. You know, those images of animals, trees, and human figures painted on stone walls. Fr--
(breathes out)
Think of these as a bowl or a deep cylinder or just look at it.
(crew laughs)
Niups--niups used bleh (crew laughs) niups neused a namera and knee obscura... Scientists now believe it took a couple days of
exposing the light for a--oo hmm bah
Hmm, hey guys, how are you?
How we doing? We good? ... who invented a way of taking pictures on paper rather than metal or (quickly) glass plate.
Marey invented what he called the chronophotographic gun. (crew laughs) Chrono.
I only said half of the se--the line
I probably say the whole thing. No
What did I do wrong? One of those engineers was a young man named William also known as WKL Dixon. (crew laughs)
His assignment was to create something that would animate photographs, something Edison would--blahblahblah pow pow!
How do we feel this is going?
We doing--we doing alright? Things like grammar, syntax, punc--punctuation.
So it makes sense that his films as impressive and influential as they were
(makes bubble sounds and chomps teeth)
Per--performative spec--ca--spectacles.
Moving on... I think I sounded a little drunk
(crew) Let's try it again.
Okay, I probably shouldn't be so drunk... or the novelty of film itself- is the novelty itself a film is enough to keep people buying
tickets. (clears throat)
(crew) Do that again.
-No, I think I
-Really?
Okay
-I conveyed it, people know what I mean.
-That's true.
Not the Hellraiser puzzle.
Oo! (Piece thuds)
(piano music)
(music stops)
-Calm- everybody calm down
-(crew) I'm sorry
-Just (Breathes in and out)
(clears throat)
Got to get ready to say this line. It's going to be good.
Yup.
(clear throat) Well the Lumiere Brothers devol--
(crew) No!
(everyone laughs)
Nice one.